- This area over here.
What do you guys want to hear a rap about?
- [Audience Member]
(faintly) Existentialism.
- Existentialism, cool.
So existentialism, well, calm down.
Did you shout fire?
You can't shout fire in a crowded room.
(audience laughs)
I'll be like, "It's time for a rap."
I was like, "No, wait, where you going?"
So existentialism.
Do you have, is there a, are you intrigued
by the philosophical
stance of existentialism?
What interests you about it?
- [Audience Member] (faintly) I was hoping
you could tell me.
- No, no.
You can't say a word that
you vaguely heard and not...
Really, I didn't expect
this kind of a grilling.
I wish I didn't exist
right now, that's ...
- [Audience Member] The absurdity of life.
- The absurdity of life, wonderful.
Thank you very much, that's good.
The absurdity of life, existentialism.
Let's come to this side.
- What do you guys want a rap about?
- Car accidents.
- Cleveland!
And what did you say?
- [Audience Member] Cleveland.
- Cleveland.
Car accidents is way more exciting.
(audience laughs)
Maybe car accidents in Cleveland.
Cool, Cleveland car accidents,
existentialism and the absurdity of life.
Back of the room, let's get you involved.
What do you wanna hear a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Lakers.
What was that?
- Lakers.
We had them suggested during
a Christmas show last month,
so I can't take that again.
Calculus and, do you hear pretzels?
Pretzels.
That's a food, but I also heard calculus.
So pretzel calculus.
Yeah, pretzel calculus,
car accidents in Cleveland,
the absurdity of life and existentialism.
This area of the front of the room,
what do you want to rap about?
- [Audience Member] Wanking.
- Wanking?
Yeah.
Ooh.
(audience cheers)
For those of you that
don't know what that is,
you will learn.
"Show us?"
My gosh, you are very attractive.
I am married, to a
woman, isn't that weird?
People get confused.
They're like, "Are you gay or British?"
No, just British.
That's, that's how we sound.
Guys over here.
So so far these have been
really good suggestions.
We have existentialism
and the absurdity of life,
car accidents in Cleveland,
wanking.
We had pretzel calculus.
You guys are the last one to go.
- [Audience Member] Ouija boards!
- Ouija boards.
Yeah, cool, I like that.
I like your Deadpool hat as well.
It's real cool.
I don't really, that's sarcasm.
(audience laughs)
I'm sorry.
Okay, I like that.
Have you ever done a ouija board?
- [Audience Member] No, my
friend's too scared to do it.
- Your friend's too scared to do it?
You guys are, like, in your early 30s.
What's wrong with you?
(audience laughs)
"No, we believe."
Do you believe in spirits?
No, why are you scared then?
You just don't wanna touch
another dude's hand on
the glass or something?
Like, "No, weird, ew."
Okay, cool.
Great suggestions.
Just to remind you of the suggestions:
existentialism and the absurdity of life,
car accidents in Cleveland,
pretzel calculus,
wanking,
and ouija boards.
This then, lovely people of
the Comedy and Magic Club,
to close out the show,
it's gonna be real fun.
It's a freestyle rap.
That is a rap made-up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions.
Don't worry, it's not gonna be anywhere
near as bad as you're expecting it to be.
(audience laughs)
You seem very unconvinced.
Let's drop our beat, good sir.
Let's have some fun.
I love how quiet you are as well.
(audience cheers)
♪ Kick it off off-hand ♪
♪ Having lots of fun
driving in Cleveland ♪
♪ On the highway, there I go ♪
♪ Oh, nice to be in Ohio ♪
♪ Got a great car, maybe Dodge Charger ♪
♪ Put a little gear shift,
yes I would rather ♪
♪ Get a manual than an automatic ♪
♪ Put my foot on the gas ♪
♪ Now I really have it ♪
♪ But I never look in the mirror ♪
♪ When I'm changing lanes ♪
♪ It's like crash, crash,
smash, what a shame ♪
♪ Now my car's a write-off ♪
♪ Take it the garage ♪
♪ Crashing in Cleveland, ♪
♪ An unholy marriage of the two words ♪
♪ That you suggested ♪
♪ A law of French philosophy ingested ♪
♪ When I was a young teenager in my room ♪
♪ You could see me wishing
death for the tomb ♪
♪ I never liked stuff, not by Camus ♪
♪ (Speaking French), what would I do ♪
♪ With me's a stranger ♪
♪ Let me translate for anyone ♪
♪ Who don't speak French, my mate ♪
♪ Life, oh, ♪
♪ Trouble and strife ♪
♪ The absurdity, why do we have it twice ♪
♪ Why can't we die ♪
♪ When we realize it's so absurd ♪
♪ Light going side to side ♪
♪ Why are you waving your iPhone, yeah ♪
♪ Put it back down ♪
♪ I don't need it there ♪
♪ Wasting all the battery ♪
♪ More flattering light ♪
♪ Keep it down on your phone ♪
♪ That's tight ♪
♪ Moving on, I'm gonna say this, guy ♪
♪ If you get a friend up in the sky ♪
♪ If they passed away up in the clouds ♪
♪ Get a little ouija
board, gather around ♪
♪ We're gonna put it on
a low-hanging table ♪
♪ Take a little glass upside-down able ♪
♪ Keep this table, put your fingers on ♪
♪ Move it around, oh, yeah ♪
♪ We got it going on ♪
♪ First letter, it says F ♪
♪ And then U, then C, and what's next, K ♪
♪ Telling you to disappear ♪
♪ But ghosts aren't real ♪
♪ Get out of here ♪
♪ Nah ♪
♪ We believe them in my head ♪
♪ I do ouija boards on
the Day of the Dead ♪
♪ I'm down low in Mexico ♪
♪ With that game ♪
♪ Played by a games
company, what a shame ♪
♪ Move on ♪
♪ Here I'm gonna take this ♪
♪ Mathematics is
difficult, can't fake it ♪
♪ I take a little beat,
good, that is Jewish ♪
♪ And I do math, yeah, I can prove this ♪
♪ Calculus is basically a baked good ♪
♪ If you can't do it
right then fake good ♪
♪ Go right to the blackboard just behind ♪
♪ And be like in A Beautiful Mind ♪
♪ Russell Crowe trying to work out X, Y ♪
♪ Get a little pretzel, twizzle it, why ♪
♪ I don't know ♪
♪ Just sit there, passive ♪
♪ In this club the pretzels are massive ♪
♪ Isn't that weird? ♪
♪ You seen the area ♪
♪ One thing that is scarier ♪
♪ Than trying to mathematics on stage ♪
♪ Is when you hear your mum coming up ♪
♪ But you've got a page of wank mag ♪
♪ Of a porno ♪
♪ Sitting over there ♪
♪ And you quickly go ♪
♪ You get a pillow ♪
♪ Cover up your shameful area ♪
♪ You hear her stills and
the steps getting nearer ♪
♪ She's right there with
her hand on the door ♪
♪ Walks in, I wish she'd
never seen what she saw ♪
♪ "Why, Chris, oh!" is
standing in the doorway ♪
♪ And I'm there just wanking furiously ♪
♪ I'm only 14, a teenage boy ♪
♪ Having wet dreams ♪
♪ Wanking ♪
♪ No hesitating ♪
♪ I go double-speed
when I'm masturbating ♪
♪ She sits there ♪
♪ Goes, "Oh no" ♪
♪ Close the door and then down below ♪
♪ Going upstairs in the bedroom's a risk ♪
♪ Then my mum wishes that
she didn't exist, yeah ♪
(audience cheers)
Oh yeah.